sur les tailles de préservatifs il faut
arrêter de se raconter des histoires
parce que par exemple petite anecdote le
fameux king size qui existe depuis de
nombreuses années ça n'a jamais été un
préservatif de grande taille c'est du 54
mm de large
or la marque qui a inventé ce modèle de
préservatifs l'a fait uniquement pour
rassurer l'homme qui achètent ces prêts
hâtif ou la femme qui achètent ces
préservatifs pour passer devant la
caissière mais ça n'a jamais été et ça
ne sera jamais une grande taille
le lubrifiant qui est sur le préservatif
ne sert qu'à une seule chose non pas à
lubrifier le rapport sexuel mais
uniquement à dérouler le préservatif et
ça personne ne le sait tout le monde est
persuadé que puisque le préservatif et
lubrifiée se lave à lubrifier mon
rapport sexuel quel que soit le type de
rapport qui soit vaginal ou anal
c'est faux c'est le meilleur moyen de
casser le préservatif et du coup d'avoir
les conséquences qui s'ensuivent qui
sont dramatiques la lubrification
vaginale n'est ni constante ni
automatique ni systématique ce n'est pas
parce qu'une qu'une femme à une
lubrification au début du rapport cavale
d'avoir pendant tout le rapport
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que deux
tailles ces fameux style le classique
elle fameuse grande taille que vous
trouvez malheureusement que dans les
pharmacies et les ventes surface il ya
au total 56 tas est différente de
préservatifs pour faire un parallèle
imaginer l'ensemble des femmes de la
planète avec uniquement deux taille de
soutien gorge ça poserait un véritable
problème ou alors l'ensemble des
terriens avec uniquement deux tailles de
chaussures tout le monde ne fait pas que
du 42e et que du 45
si le préservatif par exemple est trop
long la partie que l'on ne déroule pas
va créer un garrot à la base de la verge
et du coup ça va créer un inconfort
pendant le rapport sexuel ça peut
provoquer une perte d'érection
s'il est trop large là on se met
réellement en danger parce qu'on risque
de perdre pour des raisons physiques de
manque d'adhésion au niveau de la rampe
de la verge le fameux préservatifs et du
coup la protection saute aussi bien
contraceptive que d'un point de vue des
infections
ça a l'air simple comme ça mais le
préservatif peut être très déroutant
surtout quand on a pas ou pas beaucoup
l'habitude de l'utiliser ou quand après
une grande relation on se remet à
remettre des préservatifs pour avoir de
nouveaux partenaires et en fait faut
simplement s'entraîner donc vous mettez
chez vous provoquez à une érection parle
moins vous voulez et là vous allez le
maître et vous allez lemaitre à d'abord
avec demain vous allez mettre après vous
allez ses 2 mètres avec une seule main
vous allez il tirait vous allez même
essayer de le casser pour voir la
résistance que ça
le simple fait de s'entraîner avec un
préservatif vous permettra de dompter la
bête et de lui dire que de découvrir en
fait que c'est votre nouveau meilleur
ami